on Thursday tomorrow May 11th at 11 59
PM eastern time the title 42 Public
Health order will terminate at that
point we will once again process people
at our Southern border using our
immigration enforcement authorities
under Title VII of the United States
code
our overall approach is to build lawful
Pathways for people to come to the
United States and to impose tougher
consequences on those who choose not to
use those pathways we are taking this
approach within the constraints of a
broken immigration system that Congress
has not fixed for more than two decades
and without the resources we need
Personnel facilities transportation and
others that we have requested of
Congress and that we were not given
we have seen the effectiveness of our
approach more than one hundred thousand
people from Cuba Haiti Nicaragua and
Venezuela have arrived lawfully through
the pathway we have made available to
them and we reduce border encounters
from these groups by 90 percent between
December of last year and March of this
year
our president has led the largest
expansion of lawful Pathways ever
at the same time we are clear-eyed about
the challenges we are likely to face in
the days and weeks ahead which have the
potential to be very difficult
even after nearly two years of
preparation we expect to see large
numbers of encounters at our Southern
Border in the days and weeks after May
11th we are already seeing High numbers
of Encounters in certain sectors
this places an incredible strain on our
Personnel our facilities and our
communities with whom we partner closely
our plan will deliver results but it
will take time for those results to be
fully realized and it is essential that
we all take this into account
I cannot over emphasize that our current
situation is the outcome of Congress
leaving a broken outdated immigration
system in place for over two decades
despite unanimous agreement that we
desperately need legislative reform
it is also the result of congress's
decision not to provide us with the
resources we need and that we requested
are of her efforts within the
constraints of our broken immigration
system are focused on ensuring that the
process is safe orderly and Humane all
while protecting our dedicated Workforce
and our communities
let me be clear
the lifting of the title 42 Public
Health order does not mean our border is
open in fact it is the contrary our use
of our immigration enforcement
authorities under title VIII of the
United States code means tougher
consequences for people who cross the
border illegally
unlike under title 42 an individual who
is removed under Title VII is subject to
at least a five-year bar on re-entry
into the United States and can face
criminal prosecution if they attempt to
cross again
Smugglers
have long been hard at work spreading
false information that the Border will
be open after May 11th
it will not be they are lying to people
who are thinking of making the journey
to our Southern border know this the
Smugglers care only about profit not
people they do not care about you or
your well-being
do not believe their lies do not risk
your life
and your life savings only to be removed
from the United States if if and when
you arrive here
today we are beginning a new digital
advertising campaign in Central and
South America to counter the lives of
the Smugglers with accurate information
about U.S immigration laws this campaign
adds to our extensive ongoing
Communications efforts in the region
as you can see by the images before us
of removal flights and encounters with
our border patrol agents we are making
it very clear that our border is not
open that Crossing irregularly is
against the law and that those who are
not eligible for Relief will be quickly
returned
do not listen to the lies of the
Smugglers this is what will happen to
you
you will be returned
today alongside the Department of
Justice we are finalizing a new rule to
encourage individuals to use available
lawful safe and orderly Pathways to
enter the United States
the rule presumes that those who do not
use lawful Pathways to enter the United
States are ineligible for Asylum it
allows the United States it allows us to
remove individuals who do not establish
a reasonable fear of persecution in the
country of removal
non-citizens can rebut this presumption
only in very limited circumstances for
example
if they have used our lawful Pathways or
SCI or sought Asylum or protection in
another country through which they have
traveled and were denied
this rule goes into effect once the
title 42 Public Health order terminates
tomorrow on Thursday at 11 59 PM Eastern
Time
what I have just described are only a
few elements of an expansive effort that
began in 2021 to prepare for this
transition from the title 42 public
health authority to our tougher
immigration enforcement authorities
in addition to obtaining the first
increase in Border Patrol agent hiring
in over a decade the first in over a
decade we are in the process of surging
Personnel to the Border including more
than one thousand four hundred DHS
Personnel one thousand processing
coordinators and an additional one
thousand five hundred Department of
Defense personnel
all of these individuals will allow our
Law Enforcement Officers to stay in the
field and focus on their critical
mission
we are delivering on tougher
consequences for unlawful entry
including the return removal and
expulsion of more than 665 thousand
people during the first half of this
fiscal year we are conducting dozens of
removal flights per week and we continue
to increase our removal flight
capability
we are increasing our efficiency and
reducing processing times at the border
we launched the CBP one app which in its
four first four months helped 83
000 individuals schedule an appointment
at a port of entry and we are taking
steps to expand available appointments
we bolstered the capacity of local
governments and ngos just last week we
announced the distribution of an
additional 332 million dollars to
support communities along the southern
border and in the interior of our
country
we are leading an unprecedented law
enforcement disruption campaign that has
led to the arrest of nearly ten thousand
Smugglers who profit from vulnerable
immigrants
knowing that this is a regional
challenge that requires a regional
solution we continue to work with
countries throughout the Americas to
deter irregular migration this includes
a coordinated campaign with Colombia and
Panama to prevent individuals from
following ruthless Smugglers into the
very dangerous durian
and we are working with our partners in
Mexico regularly on a range of issues
we are a nation of immigrants we are
also a nation of laws
are immigration laws today are outdated
the solution we are implementing are the
best available within our current legal
Authority but they are short-term
solutions to a decades-old problem
the kind of migration we continue to see
today requires more resources resources
we have requested and have not received
clearer Authority and modernized
processes that only Congress can deliver
we urge it to do so
now I think we'll take some questions
thank you Mr secretary uh we just seen
some images from Texas showing that
Texas National Guard and DPS physically
blocking migrants from uh climbing up
the Riverbanks and accessing U.S soil
does the department believe that that's
a legal enforcement posture by the state
of Texas
uh Nick I'm going to leave it to the our
department of justice to to speak to the
lawfulness or lack thereof of those
actions I will tell you this uh that our
border patrol agents and our officers
work very closely with the Department of
Public Safety in Texas on the ground
when it is a coordinated and
collaborative effort it is essential
that law enforcement work as one team to
address the challenge of the Southern
border
and go ahead uh thank you Mr secretary
how many credible fear screening
interviews do you expect to conduct on a
daily basis and are you confident that
we'll keep up with the number of
apprehensions you all are seeing and
expect to see in the days
so we are of the Department of Homeland
Security with one of our agencies U.S
citizenship and Immigration Services is
indeed surging Asylum officers to border
patrol facilities as well as to
Immigration and Customs Enforcement
detention facilities to conduct an
unprecedented number of credible fear
screenings under the Asylum rule that is
going to be implemented beginning uh
upon the end of title 42. we are surging
approximately one thousand uh or more
Asylum officers for that purpose it is
very important to note
that the Asylum rule will take effect if
individuals do not access their lawful
Pathways the pathways that we have made
available to them they will face a
rebuttable presumption but a presumption
of ineligibility for Asylum they will
have to meet a higher bar this President
our president
has led the expansion of lawful Pathways
more than anyone else in our history
yes uh secretary we we have read that
the administration is considered
releasing migrants that are they are
there being carefully vetted and we just
have some teams and El Paso yesterday
observed some magnets being bitted for
an hour and then afterwards we'd release
with a permit to stay in the country for
a year I wonder how that process is
being done and how secure our you are of
those of those veterans that are taking
place
so U.S Customs and Border Protection
screens and vets individuals whom we
encounter
individuals the vast majority of
individuals will be returned those who
do not qualify from border patrol
stations or Immigration and Customs
Enforcement detention facilities
we often as has every Administration
release individuals into immigration
enforcement proceedings and those
individuals if they do not qualify for
Relief will be removed we screen and vet
individuals whom we encounter
equity
um
to follow up on the the credible fear
question can you give us an idea of what
percentage of migrants you think will be
receiving those screenings is almost
half some and can you also speak to the
agreement with Mexico I know you guys
have specifically said they're planning
to take back people from the four
nationalities to Cuban Venezuelans
icargans and Haitians but is there a
possibility that they would take back
any other nationalities as well uh
Michelle
um let me let me uh break it down a
little bit uh we are giving the option
to individuals who are in our custody
the option of voluntarily returning to
the country from which they uh came
because of the consequence
of a removal people have to understand
that under title eight of the United
States code when one is removed one
faces a at least a five-year bar to
re-entry and so we will give people an
opportunity to avoid that tougher
consequence by voluntarily returning if
they do not take that option
and they do not claim fear they will be
removed immediately
if they do claim fear they will
encounter a higher threshold under our
Asylum rule unless they have accessed
our lawful Pathways or sought relief in
another country and been denied we are
surging as I mentioned Michelle Asylum
officers to ensure that that screening
process that credible fears screening
process is done fairly
with access to council but expeditiously
immigration path to our opening sir I
mean nobody ever asked this question do
Americans gain from all the immigrants
they're bringing into the country that
drive down wages they push-up rents
sir we are a nation of immigrants and we
are a nation of laws individuals who
qualify for Relief under our laws have a
basis to remain in the United States the
contributions of immigrants to this
country is quite clear
Congress last I heard there hadn't been
a request made if you do anticipate it
like what type of criteria would would
you know trigger that kind of request
from you guys uh in December
um of this past year we sought more than
four billion dollars in funding to
address our resource needs because we
are operating within an entirely broken
immigration system and that is something
about which there is unanimity we did
not receive the funding that we
requested we received
um approximately half of what we
requested and half of what we needed
which is why we are encountering some of
the challenges uh we have sought
a reprogramming and we have communicated
to Congress that that reprogramming is a
fraction of what we ultimately need
time
you mentioned some of the immigration
proceedings the Pedro uh are you
prepared to start releasing migrants
into the U.S without court dates and
without a way to track them to reduce
overcrowding so uh when like other
administrations when we release
individuals
um we release them on conditions and
their compliance with those conditions
is absolutely necessary and if they fail
to comply we will seek to apprehend them
and remove them they are ultimately in
Immigration enforcement proceedings but
what we are speaking of what you are
inquiring of is a my a minor is a
fraction of the people that we encounter
in fact the vast majority will be
addressed in our border patrol
facilities and our ice detention
facilities
the border is open then tomorrow
absolutely absolutely not and I think
you can ask the approximately 1.4
million people who were expelled
returned or removed
from the United States this past year
that's a challenge and not a crisis
anything else
I'm sorry if you wanted to add anything
else on Regional processing centers if
not we'll we'll close remarks um let me
just uh um answer Marsha's uh question
uh if I may with respect to Regional uh
processing centers they are a powerful
example of what I expressed earlier
which is that our president has led the
expansion of lawful Pathways more than
anyone preceding him the regional
processing centers are an extraordinary
example of that leadership these are
places where we we feel on a
humanitarian as well as a security
imperative to meet people where they are
to cut the Smugglers out and to provide
them with a safe and orderly way to
arrive in the United States if they
qualify for Relief we are surging our
Personnel in close partnership with the
Department of State in close partnership
with countries in the region
we require a regional response to what
is a regional challenge we will in these
Regional processing centers screen uh
individuals uh to determine whether they
are eligible for Refugee uh status in
the United States whether they qualify
for what we are expanding in our family
reunification programs or whether on an
individualized basis on a case-by-case
basis as the law requires whether they
are eligible for other humanitarian
relief that is what we are doing the the
phenomenon of migration is different
than it was 10 12 years ago we are
seeing an unprecedented level of
migration throughout the hemisphere I
believe there are approximately 20
million displaced people in our
hemisphere
in addition the Smugglers control the
migratory paths we will cut the
Smugglers out we will reach qualifying
individuals where they are and provide
them with a safe and orderly pathway if
they arrive at our Southern border they
will meet consequences we urge migrants
once again not to believe the Smugglers
who are lying to them solely to make a
profit we are building lawful Pathways
for you to come to the United States do
not place your life and your life
savings in the hands of Ruthless
organizations thank you very much
crisis